good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day wow
when you take Monday and Tuesday off the
days are kind of stunning I had no idea
it was hump day we're not celebrating
with anyone that we love aside from each
other that's true but we're also
celebrating together in studio if you're
watching on YouTube you see Jacquees is
back not it's not Photoshop no it's real
I'm not that good she's almost there I'm
getting I'm getting there I'm back in
the studio you can hear the buzzing of
the trucks and the jackhammers it's New
York City baby Jackie's been in town
since Sunday night which means world is
in town since Sunday night and it has
been
honestly
Beyond any expectation I could have had
like really for real like having rolled
back in my life it's like oh you guys
went away but like you're back you know
yeah I'm here we have so many work
things that we're doing this week it was
also Rosh Hashanah it was Rosh Hashanah
and so it's really been a productive
week so far personally professionally
it's nice to be back with the family
have some quality time and also do like
meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcasts you know your girls are Moguls
um photo shoot photo shoot photo shoot I
hate to be that [ __ ] but like there's
really never been a better time to be a
toaster because like there's literally
so much coming
um and a lot of people thought that you
flew here intentionally to escape the
hurricane which is just you had this
trip planned in honestly your timing was
pretty great because it's hitting your
area like soon yeah the Hurricane's
supposed to really hit this afternoon
into tomorrow they're forecasting that
it's going to hit around the Tampa area
at its strength so if you are in that
area I'm sure you know what zone you're
in please be careful please you know
evacuate and do what you need to do do
Olivia was setting up some [ __ ] wild
ass videos I saw a literal picture of a
tornado yeah it was crazy and I just I'm
thinking of everyone until this
did you do anything to your house before
you left no we have hurricane Insurance
yes and we have hurricane windows and we
brought in our patio furniture oh that
doesn't go flying to the neighbors so
that's the extent of what we could do
and hopefully everything will be okay
hurricane Ian it's hard to say it's hard
to say and I don't want to be
insensitive I'm just like I just want
you guys to know what's going on in my
head at all times and when someone's
saying hurricane Ian I'm saying
hurricane Ian Miller because my daughter
married Ian Miller no I was thinking
about that yesterday that scene and I
was laughing so hard it's the funniest
quote and it's another John Corbett
sleigh
um also why I actually was thinking
about it recently is obviously because
of Hurricane Ian but I finished only
murders in the building and that [ __ ]
that uh the makeup artist on the set of
razos is the ant what you mean you don't
eat meat that's okay I make lamb she's
the aunt from Big Fat Greek Wedding I
gotta watch Big Fat Greek Wedding again
just so I can reacclimate myself like
what was that joke we used to make about
okay remember how the dad in
um My Big Fat Greek Wedding with the
grandkids like would always say like if
there was anything like any word that
came out of the kid's mouth be like you
know this word it comes from the Greek
word what was that joke we used to make
no like I would just say any word and
you say it's give me a word any word and
I'll show you it is Greek uh I really
I'm gonna re-watch just so I can like
start quoting it again and being
annoying and making it my personality
you know yeah it's time we move on from
sleepover no it's not it's never time to
move on from sleepover no no no but we
could add more but let me ask you if I
offered you a brownie or if I offered
you a stalk of celery which one would
you take these days this week
unfortunately unfortunately it would
have to be celery because I'm on a diet
ew yeah like a snatch to the gods oh man
I'd not like you no that's true I'm here
with the snatchers she's actually taking
over Margo's podcast that's one of the
big announcements that we have coming up
yeah Claudia has become this bachelor
Claudia has become the sensor
um I'm sorry mclartia mclarity
yeah it's pretty good the sweatshirt
it's like really big on me but that's
like the point yeah no for sure no but
just like it wasn't you know yeah it was
fitted yeah no we did something really
exciting this week and not to be secret
project no we're going to be secret
project [ __ ] like you're not [ __ ]
ready but our turnaround time is going
to be as short as it can be for a secret
project so hopefully within the next few
weeks like you will know what we did and
we're excited and why we did it and
we'll tell you and I feel like people
never do this we'll say this was the
secret project we were talking about on
this day we'll follow up we'll Circle
back there's never any of that people
always post on Instagram secret project
and then six months later you know it
was a photo shoot for a magazine right
like was that what you were saying was
secret yeah like this week we've done
like a few things that are all leading
up to like two major Seeker projects
that are coming like imminently yeah
like I I want to say like maybe even
next week like we're not gonna be
annoying no it's definitely next week
it's supposed to be next week but you
never know right Tinker projects are
always getting delayed right so you
don't want to over promise and under
deliver so we'll just leave it at that
but like it's been a really busy week
very productive very secretive very
secretive today I have a personally
productive day because I'm getting a
haircut everyone's talking about that
everyone's talking about my haircut no
I'm actually really excited for you
because you got into Mobile woman level
I mean I've been there no and so much of
my hair has fallen out since my last
haircut so I need fresh short or fresher
so that it can back up no not Bob but
like I am gonna cut some inches I think
like it's gonna be stuck so that it
feels much healthier it's gonna be a
tabula rasa
with the hair yeah no I can tell you I
got like a chop last week and it's
definitely given me a new lease on life
yeah I'm excited for that and then what
I'm most excited about honestly the real
reason I'm in town because I'm getting
Botox later and it's time I haven't had
Boca talks in a year and a half to two
years because I was pregnant and nursing
and your girl's wrinkly I just want to
say like you really hard not like for
someone who's apparently been like off
the wagon for a year and a half like I
would never tell I know it's not like
that bad but I got so used to and fell
in love with my forehead not moving that
it's too much movement for your girl 100
there's nothing good happens when
there's too much movement yeah that's
kind of like My Philosophy online
um wait I have like three things written
down that I don't want to forget okay
the first set like kind of like a huge
deal that I was able to announce today
is that I'm moderating a panel at
bravocon they like they're they're so
funny like when when I agree to do it
like they just like send me emails like
ver like that obviously are blasted to
all the other moderators and they're
just like leaving me out of my I'm like
here you can go I'm like they're like I
can announce they're like yeah you go so
I got a really good one I have I really
need um someone to like send this around
to all the podcasters like who canceled
because I got asked like literally four
days ago and I was like [ __ ] yes
um but it feels like they wouldn't be so
last minute you know like somebody
canceled and they needed a replacement
who lives in New York and I was you know
second rate and I'm super happy about it
but I do want to know who replaced me
yeah no I love you and I think you're
everything I know you do you're not
their first choice I can feel it in my
boat no especially like for I got like a
premium ass one I got Kyle Richards it's
the panel is all about like the
sickening vacation spots that all the
housewives have gone to so there's two
producers on it and then Kyle Richards
Luann de lesseps Kenya Moore Candace
Dillard Bessette like that's that's like
Danny Pellegrino like maybe you know
someone came up for Danny and he's not
going anymore because
I don't know why they chose me but I'm
super honored it's Sunday October 16th
on the on display stage because I'm on
display on display on display and I'm
excited I feel like it's a real honor to
have been asked even second you know
yeah you know like you're gonna be up
there shaking that thing and that's all
that matters doesn't matter maybe it was
30 then yeah no for sure I don't care
because at the end of the day like I'm
the only loser who wasn't you know
already booked and busy and I'm
available yeah yeah so it's fine yeah
I'm excited for you me too and then the
other announcement is uh Spritz is
finally being sold in New York and to
celebrate that we're going to be rolling
out across the state you know this month
but we are already in
Total Wine Westbury Plaza and on October
3rd what day is it I told him it's
October 3rd
um October 3rd which is Monday of next
week is that correct
um I am heading to Total Wine Westbury
Plaza with my husband Ben Soffer at 5 45
for a meet and greet to celebrate the
launch of Spritz in Total Wine Westbury
Plaza at 5 45 on October 3rd which Plaza
is it oh such a good question because
it's actually confusing there's multiple
blase it's the Westbury Plaza I think
yeah okay so I would love to see you all
there and we're gonna get spritzy even
though right now I'm like a little hung
like I need to not drink until Monday
October 3rd because yeah
are you okay yep I just missed Bryce and
I just wanted to oh well let's also
update everyone on Bryce yeah and I need
an update on Bryce because Bryce came
also on the trip
and he was with me for like the first
day but as stated I'm so busy it was a
lot and I don't want him just like
sitting around all day alone so he went
over to Claudius for a few nights so he
could be with Theo go on Theo's walks be
with Claudia Ben get the crew back
together again Butters everyone's back
together I need to know how my boy is
doing I miss him so but I know this is
what's best for him so he's doing really
really well um I think he really liked
it at Auntie's place I really wanted to
get him to sleep in the bed
um because Theo sleeps in the bed and
then it's like me Ben and two dogs like
it's literal Heaven however on night one
like he was
he was giving trepidation you know I
think he wasn't understanding like this
is where he's spending the night I think
he thought he was hanging out at
Auntie's house so every time he got up
it's like okay time to go home right
every time like I would get up to pee or
even just like flip over on my side to
plug in my phone bro and I was like oh
up at the door I'm like [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] back in bed because he got dropped
off at night I don't think he realized
what was happening maybe if you tried to
tonight he would be more he's been in
the crate for two nights he definitely
likes it so I don't feel bad like when
we get up he knows and he like runs in
and I've been feeding him in his crate
just to make like Theo's crate feel more
you know like a comfortable space for
him yeah
he's doing amazing like he's really
really doing incredible he's so happy to
be back on the walks with the crew he
adds like a certain Gina sequoi to the
home no he has a zest for living I can't
lie like he's been with me for like 36
hours and for like most of those hours
Ben has been in charge because I happen
to have been like so busy yesterday
um so Ben has taken on the majority of
the caregiving but starting now like
it's on me
well please continue to send me pictures
videos for updates tell him his mommy
loves him and misses him so and she's so
proud of him I will I do feel as though
we should get into it because we have a
lot to catch up on like we haven't done
a show since Friday and we also have
deer toasters and we have an update for
like one of the ones from last week that
Shook Up shook up the toaster community
so I'm ready I'm ready and then I also
have to go get my hair cut so we
obviously can't take it right no and
that's the haircut that everyone's
talking about right and they're cut it's
so important yeah so you're gonna have
like a new Gina sequoise yeah tomorrow
like you guys will see the results of
the haircut don't let me know what you
think just in case right because
negative thoughts you can't undo it and
I had one other thing to say which is
that I watched a really good movie that
I just wanted to share with the class
before the weekend I watched do revenge
on Netflix I think it's on my list
everybody's talking about it and it's
amazing and it is that movie and I loved
it Cami Mendes I love her and there were
so many great references and the plot
was great I like the beat and if you're
looking for just an easy cute movie to
watch on Netflix I would watch it again
because there was so much eye candy it
was so good and she was so incredible
yeah so that's my tip of the day do
Revenge it's on my list for sure like I
wanna I just don't know in what setting
you know I'm waiting for the right time
yeah it was the perfect time for me I
was like I don't want to read tonight
but I want to watch something not a show
because then I'll never turn it off and
I won't go to sleep movie movie
so now without further
where is Brew Theo Mrs his mama
[Music]
he's back with his friends
where is Brew his mom and Auntie are
singing because they're together and
they cannot sing when they're apart any
other songs we wanna sing while we are
together
yes
Theodora to Theodora crunchy
Angel Dora a gorgeous boys Dora
beautiful chairman Dora Flappy boys Dora
love of my life Dora long ears Dora long
neck Dora long legs Dora sexy ass Dora
fuzzy little Dora I wanna have sex with
you Dora
bestiality Dora don't knock it till you
try it
now knows Dora I love the boys maybe we
should wrap this up so we can go hang
out with them 100 but I have to get a
haircut
so now without further
Doom where are you here are the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
flip if you're not sure if that trending
skin tint is really worth the hype and
you wish that you could get the new
sheet mask ASAP instead of waiting three
to five days for shipping if you're
looking for an honest review on that new
celebrity skincare line with flip you
can have all that and more flip is the
latest Beauty app that is shaking up the
way that we can shop for beauty and
wellness imagine shopping on Sephora but
the reviews are detailed Tick Tock Style
videos and the shipping is Amazon fast
shopping on flip means you are shopping
directly with real verified users of the
product while you're browsing with over
500 Brands available on flip you can
shop all your favorite Beauty Brands and
discover new Holy Grail products through
the most honest and authentic reviews on
the market so I'm like a girly who is
easily influenced by like Tick Tock
Beauty and so flip is definitely a brand
for me and I like that they ship it so
fast because like when something's going
viral and I want to try it or like make
a video about it like I don't have time
to wait three to five like social media
waits for nobody so for The Thirst
monster and also Beauty lover in me flip
is really a fabulous product and they
have really good rewards like I got the
um super goop mineral sunscreen it was
delivered so fast and saves like over 20
percent they have really premium
products the shipping is fabulous and
it's just nice to like get honest
reviews you can up your beauty shopping
game with flip download the flip app for
free today and save 30 on your first
order with code toast 3-0 that's code
toast three zero for thirty percent off
your first order code toast 30
t-o-a-s-t-30 for 30 off your first flip
order
today's episode is also brought to you
by bowling Branch because we are bowling
Branch girlies you know you're staying
at a hotel without your bowling Branch
I'm sleeping like crap crapola crap Ola
you know who loves bowling Branch right
and that's why he went to stay at
Claudia so he could sleep with her
sheets he said Mom I'm sorry these Hotel
sheets are not up to code he's literally
Prince George from the show The Prince
like this is not it's not bowling Branch
Gotta Go Gotta Go stay I get aunties
call me when we're going home so bowling
Branch as you guys know is the official
bed sheets
store endorsed by the toast we have it
in our homes my guest room at Jackie's
house has it my home has it Jackie's
bedroom has it um they use 100 of the
best organic cotton threads on Earth for
a superior softness and a better night's
sleep their sheets aren't just buttery
not just breathable and possibly soft to
start they get softer with every wash
so I have this signature hemmed
collection I believe that's what you
have too uh it comes in a bunch of
different colors I have it in white
because it's like my Coastal grandmother
with my new like wallpaper it makes you
feel like you're in a hotel it's really
stunning and they also have fabulous bed
accessories like the waffle throw
blanket that I probably get the most
questions about on my Instagram is from
Bowling branch and with my new wallpaper
and like my Coastal grandmother moment
it goes perfectly yeah
um you'll immediately feel the
difference when you're sitting or
sleeping in a pair of their iconic
signature sheets they're free from
toxins which means no pesticides
formaldehyde any harsh chemicals their
sheets fit the deepest of mattress and
they are labeled with the bottom and top
tags so making your bed is I'm not gonna
say it's easy because it's really not an
easy Endeavor but it's easier yeah it's
more
that's such a good call it's more easy
whoever came up with that top and bottom
tag like they were using their critical
thinking skills and for that I'm
extremely appreciative and of course we
have a code we would never like rave on
and on about a brand and then not have a
code because that would be we've done
that but that's that would like not be
cool of us and we we are women who
support other women only if those women
listen to this podcast get 15 off your
sorry get 15 off your first set of
sheets when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's
b-o-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code toast
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d-branch.com promo code
toast thank you Claudia you're welcome
what is the line after you're welcome
for all the season one event and away
like you know in the Rock okay except
yeah welcome for all the toys and all
the things every day yeah I don't know
okay our first story big news
what are you doing I know I look so rude
to like be on my phone I couldn't agree
more but I don't have my iPad so it is
what it is because it's kind of used to
charging on your iPad instead of mine
it's not charging my iPad and it's all
your fault I hope you're happy because
I've told Mom
first story big news of the weekend
Rihanna will headline the 2023 Super
Bowl halftime show quote it's on the pop
star hinted at her performance at Super
Bowl lvii by posting a photo of a
football to her Instagram on Sunday it
was giving what was that photo giving if
you want to know what I'm gonna say like
we are truly the same person it was
giving something I don't know no come on
come on come on
come on
I'll give you a clue like it's a really
random it's actually not that random
okay Clint Eastwood
okay
remember when they had that reality show
yeah Mrs Eastwood and Co Mrs Eastwood
and Co and that daughter who was
sickening Francesca
um was dating that photographer Tyler
Shields and that photo is so Tyler
Shields like when we were in high school
everyone was obsessed with your Facebook
cover photo it was like a Tyler Shields
photo he did the Birkin on fire it's
basically just like a white wall and
something in front of it yeah and the
photo I would not be surprised if it was
taken by Tyler Shields did anyone else's
mind go Tyler's shield no but now that
you say it that is what it looks okay so
it's just like a hand holding up a ball
the official Twitter accounts for Apple
music and the NFL then confirmed
Rihanna's performance on Sunday saying
it's on read the Tweet okay I have like
three things to say the first is like
even though I'm the biggest 50 of all
time for reasons stated last week I am
relieved it's not Taylor Swift like I'm
not in the mood to hear blank space a
thousand times
um but I would welcome the opportunity
second of all um as she sits in her 1989
no totally I'm not being a hater I'm
being a lover like I want to protect I
heard it here first Claudia Turner no I
want to protect the Integrity of Taylor
Swift like I don't want to put her in
that vulnerable position you know sure
because if she really wanted to change
hearts and Minds like she would have to
do a three hour concert where she sings
peace on repeat you know like I just I
want the best for her always now the
thing is about Rihanna I'm Overjoyed
because girly girl is just that she's a
girly girl but this feels like you know
if I went on tour like singing do you
know what I mean it's like something I
do but like not really it's not what I'm
known for
um and I feel like I've just in the last
few years I really resigned myself to
the fact like Rihanna is a former singer
like she is now an entrepreneur Mogul
and that's my association with her like
if I had to write down what her job is
like and start a LinkedIn page for her
it would be entrepreneur Mogul so this
just feels funny to me like
like she's not a singer anymore like
forgot you know I mean I disagree I
think it's a little dramatic I know we
all want new music from Rihanna but like
she is a singer she has a huge catalog
and it's like you're always knocking
people who won't do the thing that made
them famous and here she is doing the
thing I just find it I find it hilarious
when you don't [ __ ] listen to what I
said I'm not knocking her I just said I
had a giggle I had a chuckle you're
getting caught up in the memes of like
where's the new music like no like but I
never [ __ ] said that [ __ ] are you
listening I literally never said that no
you're not gonna make me a hater because
I I'm a hater to my core but I'm not
being a hater literally I'm not taking
me all I said was that I found it komiko
like oh I don't find it I had a chuckle
I'm like oh yeah she's a singer I'm not
asking for a new album I'm actually
loving the era we have Rihanna in
currently I'm just saying my God
you can come on the show without being
[ __ ] attacked
okay you guys just saw that exchange who
was attacked yeah no you know what who's
wrong no no who was attacked sound off
in the comments well my attack was a
little bit more obvious what people will
probably see when they re-watch was
you're like [ __ ] subtle digs if you
know what he was giving he was giving
like real housewife jab no I was getting
ldp you were like digging on Rihanna
okay sorry I went to the Chuckle Hut
okay
now the other thing I wanted to say
before I was [ __ ] attacked
is we're definitely gonna get some sort
of documentary about this I feel like
it's going to be very um Beyonce getting
ready for Coachella because you know she
just had a baby she's kind of been out
of commission for a while when it comes
to performing not I'm not attacking him
just saying so I feel like we're gonna
get like a documentary of her like
training for this okay I disagree
because I think it's so you'd be such a
[ __ ] wench today like for real
[ __ ] wench Vibes I well also I might
be like totally wrong I also thought
they hadn't picked a performing it so
what do I know but Lady Gaga did it it
was cool Jennifer Lopez did it it was
cool did anyone finish watching I never
started it I don't think the school when
Jayla did it for real so I don't think
Rihanna is gonna like do something that
now other people have done it's kind of
expected no she I think she'll do it but
not
in the way that like it's not gonna be
on Netflix like she'll do it like so
cool like during a Savage show like
something you know yeah it'll be like on
patreon even though she does have like a
sickening partnership with Amazon Prime
for Fenty so she actually might just do
it with Prime and you know Prime is
where documentaries go to die like or I
could see her like finding a way because
it's weird that we don't have this where
you can watch her halftime show on Prime
like on demand like why can't I why do I
have to watch it on YouTube YouTube
videos like there should be a cat like
one streamer should have the halftime
show that's actually a really good call
and maybe that's what Rihanna will bring
to the table honestly I feel like it
would be Hulu though because they're
like all about sports they like Hulu
like sports this is not an ad but they
do I see the commercials for it YouTube
has a lot of sports too yeah
and I do believe like you need the
license I think YouTube hasn't yeah well
anyways I think it's going to be amazing
getting back to 100 point at hand do you
think she's going to bring people out
because like so many of her big songs
are like with Drake like she has like
great collabs and I would love to see a
drake moment even though oh you know I
saw uh oh man I went to dinner last
night I saw everyone first of all Cindy
Crawford
it was it was crazy to be in her
presence I also saw Travis Scott he
looks exactly what you think like
whatever he looks like in pictures
that's exactly what he looks like it's
actually
I was like I thought like it was crazy
like I was like am I looking at a
picture like it was just people you may
see them in real life up close like they
always look different exactly the same
cool yeah it's Poppin I think she'll
bring out guests but I hope she doesn't
I wish she wouldn't I know
yeah I'm so sick of the medleys
I want a one-woman show
um yeah she's capable of that yeah I
want like a Katy Perry extravagant she
brought out Lenny Kravitz
when she did her iconic Missy Elliott
that's weird she brought out Lenny
Kravitz and then they ended up on um
American Idol together
Lenny Kravitz
okay sorry I do get Lenny Kravitz that's
sneezing it is because they both have
like famous kids yeah wives both like
Nicole yeah sorry I do get them confused
because also I don't know any of their
music but they're both so famous yeah no
I accept hello it's Ben's favorite song
[Music]
I can see it in your eyes I can see it
in your smile
sorry yeah so what did she perform with
Lenny Kravitz I forget got it okay I
don't even that's so funny because I
just remember like her being on that big
lion I don't remember he wasn't on the
lion no I'm saying Twisted I don't
remember her bringing people out yeah no
she brought the two of them it was a
really great show but like Lady Gaga one
woman show love That Lady Gaga's is my
favorite I think in recent
actually Bruno Mars and Beyonce was
pretty sickening too Coldplay was there
though and who cares yeah the one thing
about me is like
I don't I don't really want to say it
but like I don't really [ __ ] with
Coldplay like I follow them on Tick Tock
and they're doing this thing and like I
really appreciate them trying to help
the environment I do
um where like you show up to their
concert early and ride a bike to create
energy to power the show and it's like
so not only do I have to pay for these
tickets I have to work the show I wear
this show isn't that crazy they have all
these bikes like people during the show
and before the show you can come early
and do it and then during the show you
can ride
and I'm not sure it really can be
helping the environment that much I'm a
little skeptical I thought you were
going to say like you come you ride
bikes and we're storing like salt wind
power to you know help no they're
powering the show because they're trying
to decrease their footprint which I get
I totally get that they would like be
powering a village and I just think if
I'm gonna get on the bike like I want a
discount you know or like you should be
paying me cash for every five minutes
I'm on this bike
I thought it was a little dick but like
there it's actually like they're crazy
no I know but like their fans like love
them and like love that Vibe of like
decreasing the footprint so they like I
think there's like a line for the bike
like so that's what I'm saying is like I
will never be one of those people even
though like when they were just here at
MetLife like it did look unbelievable
like I do want to hear Jerusalem Bell
singing you know yeah and there's a few
songs that really get me yeah but for me
like any kind of affinity and like
positive vibe I have for Coldplay like
really has to do more with Gwyneth
Paltrow than anything else yeah because
she was so beautiful and stunning and
broken-hearted that he was moved to
right fix you you know he will fix you
when they broke up no when her dad died
he was like she was so like perfect and
just really perfect inspiration for a
song and that's the thing about Gwyneth
Paltrow like
come for her because she is that [ __ ]
like the greatest song of all time just
happens to be written about her yeah she
is that [ __ ] and I also love the Dakota
Johnson of it all because I literally
okay so there's you're gonna love this
there's this trend on tick tock where
they take the Kanye sing song
human beings in a mob
what's a mob to a King
what's a king to a god
what's a god to a non-believer so what
they do is like they keep leveling up so
it's like human beings in a mob and it
was um the crowd at The Ellen Show
wait Ellen yeah like people who [ __ ]
love Ellen okay so they're like they're
the human beings in a mob and then it's
like what's a mob to a King and they had
like her DJ you know like they level up
and then they had Ellen what's a what's
a what's a king to a God and the God is
Ellen and then it's Dakota Johnson
what's a god to a non-believer because
she was the one who like brought down
Ellen I'll send it it's funnier in video
than it is
no no no sorry but I've recently become
like kind of obsessed with Dakota
Johnson
um and so any Affinity I have for
Coldplay comes from her as well because
I support women yeah in this situation
not in all situations just want to
clarify got it got it so uh Rihanna the
Super Bowl
cool this is great news I'm so happy I'm
so relieved it's better than I could
have imagined I agree and you know what
that means we still have Taylor Swift
and pink to look forward to and as well
and what about Kelly Clarkson have we
ever thrown her name out Queen the thing
is and I hate to like keep like I'm
definitely I came to the show with an
agenda today and that and every day that
agenda is to get you back on Tick Tock
and I think one of the things that could
get you back on Tick Tock is if you knew
how like this younger generation is
learning about Kelly Clarkson and
developing this
enormous amount of respect for her like
so many of her random songs have gone
viral
um her Kelly Okies that she does on the
Kelly Clarkson show like they get picked
up a thousand times over there is a
place for you on on Kelly talk on Kelly
Clark talk I just need to get my account
back it's not about me oh yeah what
happened I haven't heard anything from
anyone if you work for tick tock please
help me it's really I will get Tick Tock
like I'll be on it on my iPad that way I
can when it's got used to your iPad
instead of mine yeah that way I don't
get addicted to it on my phone
but I can't get into my account and I'm
not starting a new account and no no and
you have so many iconic videos iconic
and my handle's Jackie oh like we'll get
it back somebody
I'll put a call out on my Instagram like
you that ain't right yeah it ain't
[ __ ] right
so Rihanna Rihanna is going to be
wonderful it's fabulous and we do need
to move we need to move on yeah because
we have a lot to do today and I have to
get my haircut what are we like already
30 minutes in 40. it's hard to see yeah
it's hard to know
I think it's almost 40 based on the time
okay let's get to it next up Haley
Bieber reveals she has spoken to Selena
Gomez since marrying Justin oh okay I
watched like while I was getting ready
today maybe 30 minutes so I didn't get
to that part that's interesting okay so
Haley Bieber is on call her daddy I
think it dropped at midnight last night
and she revealed she had spoken to
Selena Gomez since marrying Justin
Bieber in September she said quote it's
all respect it's all love good when
Haley insisted there is no drama
personally between her and uh Selena
Alex asked whether they have talked the
model said yes noting that Selena
doesn't owe her anything she explained
neither of us owe anybody anything
except respect I respect her a lot and I
think there are no expectations between
us I respect her everybody on our side
knows what happened and we're good and
we can walk away
from it with Clarity and respect that
has brought me a lot of Peace we know
what happened it is what it did oh wow
okay because I watched the first like 30
minutes and I was hella bored I was like
well let's and and I was bored while we
were talking about the good stuff like
I'm like why am I bored
um and I kind of just like honestly
and I love Haley Bieber so like I wasn't
watching the interview to have my mind
changed like I could watch her fart like
she's so [ __ ] beautiful
um but she was like talking about this
thing that like has been following them
and haunting them for so long and I just
found it kind of boring I kind of wish
Alex had like dug a little deeper I felt
like like she would ask a question and
then Haley would answer it and like kind
of like Drop jewels and that that
required further questions and then we
just like moved on to like how'd you
pick out your outfit today I I wish we
went a little deeper and maybe that was
like one of the things they had to you
know agree to in order to get Haley on
like she's one to speak her piece and
not you know but they broached the
subject yeah no honestly she clearly
didn't say like don't ask me about
silver I gotta keep an eye out
personally and by the way Haley the
whole time like At first I was like why
does her eye look like that and then I
realized she was keeping an eye out for
Celine or
um I just felt like it wasn't a great
interview okay I haven't watched it
because I I mean I haven't had time for
midnight till now and I might just to
like see Haley in action stunning like
you you could die like there's been a
lot of chatter and that people think
it's strange that she's like doing this
okay down right when Selena's about to
drop a six-year documentary and by the
way I'm sure that she is by the way and
I'm fine with that this thing has like
[ __ ] followed Haley Bieber her whole
life like every single person on the
planet had a boyfriend or a girlfriend
before they met you it's not a crime and
the way like people are so [ __ ]
mentally ill when it comes to Jelena
it's not normal because you don't know
these people you don't know what
happened and it's not on you to get
Justice for Selena Gomez it's not like
she's a grown woman and she will heal in
her own time and I love all three people
involved and I am uh you know stable
enough to realize that people
friends get bored friends get married
strangers get born and strangers get
buried like life goes on people move on
but I'm right where you left me wow that
song is literally about Jelena stands
like everyone's Moving on but I'm right
where you left me yeah
um still let the restaurant still do you
think that's what Taylor wrote about
still sitting in the corner I haunt
literally
I just to me she seems like she has so
much more going on than like Selena but
I'm just so removed from it like when I
think of Haley and Justin like I don't
think about Selena like I don't think I
think I'm the exception I don't think
that Haley Bieber can wake up a single
day without hearing the word Selena like
on her phone like I think it's so I
think your phone I yes and I think she's
probably does that but I think like
she's trying to run a business and be a
celebrity and like do all these things
and like she can't go on Instagram live
without literally the comments being
Jolina okay you can do you can run a
business be a celebrity without ever
going on Instagram live yeah you know
what I mean he's an influencer and by
the way she literally has our like gen Z
and a [ __ ] Chokehold like she is the
Taste maker of Our Generation yes so and
and she's
cashing in on that like with Road and
she's becoming like this style and
Beauty icon and she just wants to do
that in peace yeah
and for for us I think like maybe it
doesn't seem like the biggest deal but I
think like she's confronted by it
literally every moment of every day and
it's about to come up even more with
Selena's documentary and you know what
two things can be true at the same time
like Selena's experience can be her
truth and ju and Haley's experience can
be her truth and they can both coexist
like people experience things
differently and like I don't Haley
basically my take away from the first 30
minutes that I watched was like the
timeline is what people really like have
a problem with like they think that
Justin cheated on Selena with Haley
um
and she's like that's just not true yeah
like I was there I lived it your
perception of it can be one thing but I
[ __ ] lived it and it's not true and
she was cursing too I was living for it
right and I just have to say like I'm
not endorsing cheating or anything but
like okay so say that they did even
though I believe her when she says that
they didn't yeah even if they did and
you're so bent out of shape about it
like five years later five years later
they are married they couldn't be more
Rock Solid go away you know it's like at
some point you have to forget you know
yeah
and it's just like it's it's people not
being okay that's what it comes down to
like true truly unwell human beings
um so I didn't need this interview you
know what I mean it's not like she
cleared all this up like I [ __ ] love
Haley Bieber and you know what I love
Selena like I just finished only murders
I thought she was excellent I have like
a problem with the second season in the
sense I couldn't follow what the [ __ ]
like what were we investigating I didn't
even remember and I really I really
truly didn't care who ended up doing it
I was just loving the gals being back
together of course the way I would lay
my life out on the line lay down in
oncoming traffic for Martin Short is not
normal and those are words I truly never
thought I would say like back before
yeah I'm like Martin Short I'm like is
that the guy who like went to jail for
big Pharma
shkreli right
um obsessed but
spoiler alert I think at the final 30
seconds of the show there's another
murder so that we have next season and I
just feel like they don't really need to
keep doing that I feel like they could
this show obviously second season made
them into Joe Rogan like they're The Joe
Rogan of podcasting in the show and I
would love if we could follow their
lives as like Moguls who every season
investigate a random murder like maybe
they leave New York one season and
investigate kind of how Becky in
Oklahoma like yeah I don't think it
needs to keep being like people they
know dying but because it's almost
unbelievable it's only murders in the
building but that's what the podcast is
called so like we don't we don't need to
be in the building anymore that's what
I'm saying I do think we've exhausted
the building no but like that's why they
got into
it but also it seems like this murder
happened on spoiler but it's not really
the stage so it's out in the building
we're already leaving the building right
unless the actor is someone who lives in
the building
Paul Rudd
that was a nice little surprise yeah
okay so all I'm saying is like you can
love Selena and you can love Haley and
you can love Justin and I'm living
breathing proof of that and you can also
be stable I'm a stable person I agree I
just feel like there's so many more
interesting things about her what else
do they talk about from what you saw
like
like let me actually see how much of it
I watch because I watch what I was doing
my makeup but I was um
because honestly like they covered one
topic while I was okay listen to 28
minutes yeah so maybe I missed a lot but
the first 28 minutes were covering the
timeline like it was actually really
slow like okay got it but I am gonna
finish it because I would love to hear
her talk about conversation with Selena
that's crazy I don't think she said what
she said to Selena she said yes why
we've spoken yeah I think Haley respect
Haley was giving us everything and
nothing at the same time and we stand a
queen you can do both you know yeah
are you ready for our next story I am
but like
the fact that
through our work we kind of discovered
the true meaning behind right where you
left me by Taylor Swift like that is
crazy
you think it's about Jelena stands yeah
because everyone else has moved on with
their lives except for you
because you're right where you left me
think about it our next story is some
fashion news Kim Kardashian because
we're a bunch of fashion girlies we're
such fashionistas Kim Kardashian debut
Dolce Gabbana collaboration at Milan
Fashion Week ciao Kim Kim took her
design talents to mon Fashion Week this
season teaming up with Dolce and Gabbana
on The house's spring summer 2023
fashion show
September joggers you're literally sure
models walk the runway in the collection
of reworked archival looks curated by
Kim while a black and white video of
this game's founder eating spaghetti and
the sound of clicking Paparazzi cameras
played in the background per L UK the
color palette was kept mostly to blacks
metallics and leopard print with some
models wearing choker necklaces that
spelled out Kim in bold letters also
many members of her family including
Chloe Chicago Saint North and Chris
we're in attendance to support right
everyone's kind of talking like Chloe
totally eclipsed Kim's Moment by being
photographed with Michelle from 365 days
who is the hottest man alive and people
are like she's gotta get dick down in
Milan with a guy from 365 days like he
needs to take her captive for a year and
we can fall in love because that's what
happens in the movie
um I completely agree like the way I
need these two to start [ __ ] like now
it's not normal
um I I would if I had to I would lay my
life out online just so they could have
that moment together and do I I think
it's the end I'll be all for her no but
like she needs to have some fun she does
some fun and this man is literally
there's not a hotter man and he was like
very clearly and her like following her
around the club and they were filming so
like I hope we'll get a Michelle moment
that's so cute yeah
um so that was what really everyone was
talking about and I feel like nobody
cared about the fashion show Kim looked
amazing like the whole vibe is like you
know glamor Milan spaghetti Marilyn
Monroe
um it's not like the most like creative
like different idea but she looked
fabulous so you know could I ask you
something do you think it's like
Courtney is feeling some type of way
that like this was her partnership with
her wedding and now why wasn't she there
I don't know if she's feeling any type
of way but like let's let's be really
real with one another
um that partnership only existed because
Kim exists you know what I mean so maybe
she utilized the partnership first but
the roots to the partnership connect to
Kim right but like Kim never was like a
Dolce girly in like publicly like this
like she's always been like so high
fashion like always wearing futuristic
looks and now all of a sudden she's like
like really leaning into this style that
was like inspired by Courtney's wedding
no which I wouldn't say anything I was
amiss except for the fact that Courtney
wasn't there so let me say this let me
say this I think if we're gonna Trace
back to like the Kardashians
relationship with dng I think it
probably goes back to Simon Hawk and
Kris Jenner who go to that show every
year like stay at the castle go on the
boat with the dng like they're a part of
the gng family they're oh like I just I
know for the last five years every time
I watch Instagram in the summer like
Simon is there with Chris yeah so so you
think it's Chris's relationship and
Simon I honestly think like Simon made
the intro and I don't know this even
though like I know Simon I can literally
ask I think if I had to guess like Simon
made the intro for the family to dng
like he's been like part of the dng
family for as long as I've known him
like going multiple times a year got it
to the show got it I just wonder when
the wedding partnership like who
facilitated whose idea was that who
reached out to who honestly I would say
Chris
it was amazing it's an interesting take
though I didn't think about it because
like
who cares of Courtney's there like she
doesn't go to Fashion Week all the time
she was like the dng bride and like she
made the whole family and like it I
don't know if they I mean everything
that they do becomes a moment but it
just became like so much bigger than
yeah just like a wedding weekend in
Italy yeah it was a whole fashion
campaign and now it is the face but like
that became Kim's aesthetic because she
had to wear those outfits you know right
and I think she liked what she saw she
liked what she saw to be like dressed in
like what Dolce does it's like they
dress a woman's body yeah it's very
feminine it's not the stuff that she
like Balenciaga
silhouette shapes you know it's very
like traditional Timeless sexy no I love
and at the same time and Tommy and she
started doing her hair right right and
Chloe's not working that uh Crystal and
black jumpsuit that Kim had worn at the
wedding she looked amazing and the kids
were wearing mini versions of it Chicago
the show I mean you said Michelle is the
reason for the season Chicago has taken
the Internet by storm 100 lollipop and
her sunglasses it was a fabulous
fabulous moment
um
Kendall wasn't there either right
no see like to me that's more obvious
because Kendall's literally like the It
Girl of modeling why wouldn't she just
model in the show and that's what they
were talking about in the teaser for
this week's episode Kim is going to
Prada and she calls Kendall and is like
do you want to fly with me she's like
I'm so waiting to hear if I booked if I
booked it because like I auditioned or
whatever and it's like you're obviously
going like so she could walk in any show
she wants but it might be a conflict I
don't know how those things work you
know
with what like Kendall is the face of so
many Brands yeah she can't just lend her
face to every single one like I'm sure
there's like non-competes she's like
long champ now she's Louis Vuitton like
she's everything yeah so maybe there's a
conflict
yeah also I think maybe Kendall was
working Milan Fashion Week and like just
couldn't just drop everything and go to
the show like that's so crazy because
like you and I found ourselves in Milan
the same week and like I was there
working and you were there working like
we would go to each other's events like
I know but maybe that's just like we're
not as busy as them no and we're like
they're desensitized to like the fame of
it all and like we're like Milan yeah
and like every the big deal of it all
even though this felt like it was a
really big deal for Kim she's like is
posting a million times and it is a big
deal she looked amazing yeah and she had
so much like creative input it's not
just her face no yeah she was designer
girly yeah great partnership stunning
where it just looks everyone really
turned it out gorgeous moment gorgeous
moment
our next story
little drama at SNL but like not really
Keenan Thompson's estranged wife is
dating his former SNL co-star Chris Redd
wait what Keenan Thompson's estranged
wife has moved on from the longtime SNL
star with one of his former co-stars
wait this is [ __ ] weird though Chris
it is but there's like no beef Christina
Evangeline is dating Chris red TMZ
Christina Evangeline that's like a
really close to Christina wait
Evangelista I love angelista oh okay
sorry I was thinking of the wrong person
it's dating Chris red team is he married
to the biggest Superman Laurel claiming
there's no bad blood between Keenan and
Chris over the new relationship sources
close to the new couple told the outlet
that Chris red and Christina became
official with the past year and that
there was no cheating or overlap in the
relationships in fact Keenan and
Christina reportedly have been living
Separate Lives since 2019. Reps for the
Stars didn't immediately returned page
six's request for comments no it's
[ __ ] weird it's just weird because
it's like well how did they meet no and
it's like of all the girls that you
could date why do you choose the one who
used to be married to your co-worker
like it's
hella unnecessary and I don't even think
they're divorced yet like they're
obviously not together they're saying
there's no bad blood but like if you're
a human being like you you would be even
if even if Keenan and his wife had the
healthiest split of all time and they
genuinely like love each other as
friends but it didn't work out even in a
situation like that we are it is The
Human Experience to
find this weird like it's weird yeah
and it honestly like makes me think like
weird things about Chris Webb like
honestly like I'm thinking weirdly when
I I don't think I ever thought of him
period you know yeah but now I'm gonna
think of him as like the guy who like
stole his co-workers Mr Steal Your Girl
it's Mr steal your wife like that's what
makes it even weirder I'm sorry I'm
calling it like this is weird
I don't think that there was anything
nefarious that happened I think they
split and then they started dating and
the timelines are fine I think it's
weird but
how can you be such good friends with
someone like now every time you see them
they're with you or white agreed I don't
think there's anything nefarious but
that doesn't take away from the
weirdness yeah of choosing of all the
girls and all the bars like
you had to walk into Keenan's house and
take his wife
it's weird
okay well good luck to the couple I hope
they find love and I wish finds love as
well maybe we should add them to the
list yes by the way influencers I feel
like you know I feel like I've actually
said the story a lot
like for some reason whenever I get into
Ubers and like start chatting they
always love to share like famous people
they've driven yes we know and on more
than one occasion I've had a driver who
drove Keen into and from SNL and they
all had wonderful things to say about
him I think he's like he would make a
really good husband what about Keenan
and Chloe I was thinking that too and if
Kim and Pete were still together that
would just but honestly I don't see it
working because Keenan is so SNL and
he's so New York like he's I think you
know Pete was very much like
SNL was a part of his career not his
career and Keenan like puts a show on
his back he literally has a hernia from
all the work he does I think like he
needs to have someone New York based
maybe it could be Chloe and Keenan take
New York no but see like I would never
encourage a relationship that requires
somebody to move across the country from
their family but obviously that's
something you would do
yeah for love for what's right yeah you
know maybe like LA's not working out for
Chloe I think it is I think maybe Kim
was just on Kelly and Ryan she was
talking about school drop-off did you
say no it was I haven't seen any I've
just been like I literally haven't been
on my phone it was really cute she was
talking about Kelly was like when you go
to school drop off like what do you wear
she was like I wear spandex like I come
from the gym I'm wearing gym clothes
um and it's like always really emotional
but like
Chloe stays there all day like literally
outside the classroom crying
he's really sweet so like she's very
connected to family she's not going
anywhere okay okay well maybe Keenan
could give it all up for Chloe that
would be she's someone that you give it
all up for but then like that causes
resentment oh for sure like he's like
five years from now my career right
right like he's shirking and whatever
sure okay our fifth and final story
something that Claudia just caught me up
on there's drama with beauty influencer
Michaela Kaylor naguera yeah she is
under Fire for complaining that her job
is different listen I experienced the
whole thing so I'm gonna tell you okay
you don't want me to read from no ciders
no perspective so Michaela niguero is
literally she was on that Forbes list
remember we were talking about her and
they said she made two million dollars I
know who she is you've talked about her
a lot you're very influenced by her I
buy all of her [ __ ] a makeup tick tocker
yeah and she's like from Boston and
she's this crazy accent
um so she's like she's not like other
makeup gurus you know yeah and so this
she went on live a year ago and said
this thing and then somebody posted uh
cut down version of it on talk and it
went viral so viral that I actually use
the sound and then when I found out what
it was I deleted my Tick Tock it was
just I was making a joke about try being
an influencer for a day try it like it
was a joke am I do delete it because I'm
not I'm not gonna contribute you don't
want to pile a lot no because honestly
like dresses for Michaela and here's why
so here's what she said the clip that's
going viral just The Abridged version is
like this
I'm just finishing work for the day and
it's 5 19. try being an influencer for a
day try it now obviously you just hear
that and it's a girly uh
you're not a coal miner like calm down
it's five it's like it's beyond and it
sounds extremely out of touch now with
context it's still a little out of touch
but it's not um and this isn't a girl
who had anything handed to her like she
was working up until I think two years
ago at Ulta she's worked her whole life
in retail like we thought that's when
when I started first started following
her I was like really early she worked
at Ulta and that's why she had like such
um expertise right people trusted her
her opinion so this isn't a girl who is
like privileged by any means like she's
worked super hard
um and when you watch the the full
version of the clip she was basically
sitting down for dinner going on live
and she was like oh I'm just tired like
I had a long day like any normal [ __ ]
human being complains about being tired
and that somebody like left a nasty
comment like must be so hard and so she
basically just responded saying you know
I woke up at six she told us exactly
what she did for the day she's like I
edited three videos I shot some branded
content I had four meetings and then I
did this and now I'm just now sitting
down for dinner 19 I'm just trying yeah
so she got like a little salty at the
end
um with context it's obviously much
better
um and it's important to remember that
she didn't suggest we Slaughter all the
children of the world like she just was
being you know you tuned into her live
and she was talking about her life so I
think this person you don't know what
the comments I guess does the video is
there screen recording does it have the
video I don't know I don't know you
don't know what people are slinging what
she was responding to yeah and let's
just say for argument's sake that there
was no context and all she did was
complain about being an influencer is
that out of touch yes does she deserve
what's literally being thrown at her
like no people are so [ __ ] crazy
um and I find it really interesting that
the new hot button issue like the last
couple of things I've seen people get
canceled for like happen on Tick Tock
this girl Tara's world was like I'm
literally so productive like I and she
was like it sounded like definitely out
of touch like but again she wasn't
suggesting we Slaughter all the children
of the world she was just like
I'm literally so productive like how are
you like not working like you guys are
like like that could never be me like
and she got her ass [ __ ] handed to
her the new hot button issue is like you
cannot talk about working if you're an
influencer no but even like Kim saying
yes get your [ __ ] ass up and work
okay so like why are people so sensitive
about this yeah
this new I've noticed that I'm going to
be steering clear of this topic like and
I guess people don't want to going head
first people don't want to be told by
people who have jobs that appear to be
much easier that they have to work
harder because it's the way the coal
miner says get your [ __ ] ass up and
yes they'll accept that yes yes I don't
think they would yes yes they would it's
it's not what they're saying it's it's
who's saying it I think that's why
people are getting so bent out of shape
because it goes without saying that like
being an influencer everyone's job is
hard in some way and part there are
parts of being an influencer that are
super hard but it's not nearly as hard
as you know working in uh food service
or working as a coal miner or a truck
driver the coal miners who are offended
no they're the only ones who can the
people who are offended are like you
know the people who are always offended
it's like right it's white women like No
And so it's nonsense who work nine to
five like cushy jobs for sure and who
spend all that time commenting on social
media so obviously they're not working
that hard I just feel like it's so
important that you add that part to the
conversation like the amount of time
people are spending like tearing down
Michaela when they should be working I
just think it's important so I'm team
Nick Michaela because she really didn't
say anything that [ __ ] bad and if
you're that if you're really that upset
like you absolutely have to go outside
you absolutely have to go outside and
remember like the internet is not a real
place you don't know Michaela personally
and you need to calm the [ __ ] down
because literally Michaela is like part
of her platform is like she pretty much
like gets on social media once we can
just balls her eyes out about how she
cannot fight her depression like she is
so depressed and she's like literally
she's had unparalleled success like I
don't think she'll do a branded Tick
Tock for any less than 100 Grand like
she bought a house like and she did not
grow up like that like she is having
unpressed and she says like these
unbelievable things are happening to me
and I've never been more depressed in my
life like she's really vocal about how
like her depression is so bad she's had
it her whole life like in high school
she went through a really bad bout and
it's come back now and it's confusing
for her because she's never been more
famous or more successful or this should
be the happiest time of her life so just
keep that in mind when you're like
yelling at her for something she said on
Instagram live a year ago that you
didn't even have context for like you're
all nobody not okay it's like no one is
okay like take a step back the way that
the needle is moving like to things that
like sometimes you'll tell me like some
girls are getting canceled they said
this and I'm like you're lying I'm like
really that's not gonna stick like I
know and really what were we talking
about the girls who said on that podcast
that they would never date someone sober
and then they literally posted these
like hostage videos apologizing and it's
like
um okay so you wouldn't date someone
sober like they said If You're Sober
you're boring and so if I was a sober
person like maybe that would offend me
would I demand an apology no I would
stop listening to the podcast no but
like or I would disagree you could
disagree with something without being
offended by it like oh my God
oh my God yes it's not either just
offended or not offended like you could
disagree oh I don't think that's true or
I see it differently and I still love
these girls and oh on this point we just
didn't agree
it's not like we say something on the
show you disagree with it and so you
have to stop listening to our podcast
like no one's going to agree with a
hundred percent of the things that we
say
that thing again you don't you can
disagree with something without being
offended by it oh my God you are
literally Aristotle like Jack astoddle
that is so [ __ ] true it's not
offended or not offended yeah because
like I said that's why I keep saying
like it's not like she said you know I
hate all Jews like it's not it wasn't
even offensive thing it's somebody's
opinion yeah that you disagree with oh
my God you just literally blew my mind
because I'm so like deep in Internet
culture sometimes I can't see out of it
as like a human being you know yeah and
you just brought my head right out yeah
no it's so crazy and also sometimes like
I'll look at situations like months
later and even in that moment I'm like
oh my God I can't believe they did that
or yeah and then months later I'm like
are we joking yeah no I feel that way
about someone's cancellation but I'm not
gonna say who it is because I feel like
people still think it's crazy I feel
that way about a lot of people's
cancellations yeah like in the moment it
was really bad but now like years later
you just realize like they just like
they actually made a mistake and like
it's okay like we're all human beings
but in the moment it feels so crazy yeah
yeah and like I feel like we owe people
apologies for how much we [ __ ] ruin
their lives on the internet I'm not
saying wait sorry because I'm not I'm
not like you I'm not like you I don't
[ __ ] do that I didn't take up for
them yeah not that you piled on but like
you didn't help yeah I wonder if people
are going to come to that realization so
hard because when someone's going
through something like it's a sinking
ship and like why would anyone on board
no and I like I want to I have values
but also I remember a time when like I
was getting my [ __ ] life canceled
like every minute it was another thing
and I don't really remember anyone
coming to my defense except literally
Taylor Striker it's not even about that
like oh this person wasn't here for me
so uh or people weren't there that's
what it's about from here for them it's
like you have a business you have a
career and like you can't just keep
going down with every ship like right no
because that's the cycle of cancel
culture it's like you could get canceled
for commenting on someone else's
cancellation and who the [ __ ] wants that
no nobody's worth that [ __ ] it's so sad
but it's so true so you just kind of
have to be like yeah you have to be like
late yeah yikes oh I will say I will
never say that about when I don't agree
I will never do that like I will never
buy it on to something or want to say
someone if I don't think that they did
something one thing about the Michaela
naguero situation that's actually really
important to bring up is that you know
now that you know her cancellation is
happening people are doing a deep dive
looking for old tweets old Tumblr posts
whatever and what they found was
actually I don't think something we've
ever experienced yet Michaela is a
former troll
so her comments on Jaclyn Hill's
Instagram from like 2017-2018 where her
thing like one of everything everyone
knows about her is like she's Jaclyn
Hill's biggest fan
um and she actually used to be a Jaclyn
Hill troll like she left a comment on a
picture she says she loved to comment on
one of Jaclyn Hill's pictures
um of her house and was like must be
nice to make videos and just be rich for
it and she actually left a non-ironic
yikes on one of her pictures
um and I think she posted a picture like
with her man and Michaela was like ew
like she's a former troll that I think
is more interesting than the working
conversation but that's just me yeah so
I just want to say also you could look
at it alternatively where it's like she
used to be the same type of person that
are now commenting and coming for her
and it's like she used to think oh you
work you post a video a day and now you
have this house that's literally what
she said and now she's experienced so
she's someone who's literally commenting
on her stuff right now yeah being like
you I think it's so hard to be an
influencer and so if that person becomes
an influencer you go and they're like oh
my God it's so hard like uh try it and
then you go back and it's a cycle and
y'all are crazy and get off the [ __ ]
hamster wheel no get off the internet
like for real some people just really
can't handle it it's so crazy and it's
like you live like if you either die
the hero or you live long enough to see
yourself become the villain no by the
way that is literally what's happening
so just everyone take a step back Taylor
is gonna be she's fine leave her alone
she hasn't posted them she had a bad day
and also like it's not even like we have
to make excuses for what she said which
she said like you try being an
influencer try it you know I think what
she was trying to say for more people to
try you know and I think that what she
was trying to say is like
the perception of what you don't know
what comment she's responding to right
who the you is yeah but who's someone
who's being like Oh you're an employee
you work one hour literally herself her
old self right I think the her old self
I think the point she was just trying to
make is like it looks being an
influencer is definitely of all the jobs
in the world not even close to being a
hard one but I think it's a little bit
more difficult than people assume I
think people assume you sleep in you
post one video you make a million
dollars and you go back to sleep
it's not what it is it is more laborious
than that and I think a lot of the work
that goes into it you don't see because
that's the point that's the point it's
still not a difficult job I'm
acknowledging that I've had real jobs
and I've had influencer jobs and I know
what the difference is
um but that's not to say that it's not a
little bit more involved than what you
might think well if you think you wake
up make a million dollars and go back to
sleep then it's a lot more involved than
that but even like for the people who do
Post most of their hustle it's more
involved than that and then you also
have to think about like the mental
aspect of it and the fact that she is
struggling with depression so it's like
doing all of this and this is a job that
just would exacerbate any of that no and
being an influencer is the one job in
the world I think more so than being a
traditional celebrity where the hate you
get is
unparalleled like you it is not normal
the amount of [ __ ] you have to hear
about yourself and your family and
people you love about their physical
appearances about [ __ ] from their past
it is worse than any major celebrity
ever experiences the [ __ ] websites
that are created about you like they
don't run their own social media and
even if they do it's like I'm like my
juice today and everyone's like oh my
God you're so great no but there's not
there's none of them aren't even on
social media and there's not dedicated
places for people to talk about Hillary
Duff in order for you to do your job as
an influencer you have to actively like
enter all of these spaces where people
are hating and one thing about me is
I'm always going to take the side of an
influencer because I feel like in a lot
of ways they are usually in being
wronged not that's not to speak for
everyone because a lot of them are
[ __ ] morons too um but that's any job
because there's a lot of moronic
accountants you know there's a lot of
moronic coal miners it always comes back
to the coal miners that's the thing I
don't feel like there's moronic coal
miners no that I completely agree
actually Derek Zoolander was it coal
miner he comes from a coal mining family
member he goes back and he like can't
handle it for a day oh is that the C the
news no in the OG no I honestly don't
remember that's [ __ ] funny no it's
funny like
yeah
yeah
that's funny yeah okay
should we push your toasters to tomorrow
yeah because we had a lot of catching up
to do today we don't have a TV recap
actually I do I I have a few things to
say I think we should do your toasters
yeah because also um I finished only
murders in the building and I just want
to talk about it really quickly and I
watch Game of Thrones did you watch nope
we got new reniro though let's talk
about that we can't no no we I haven't
watched anything we I can't talk about
it I'll see you next Tuesday
okay well dear toasters is brought to
you by Caraway it's time to ditch the
chemicals with Caraway homes non-toxic
cookware and bakeware collections so you
can make healthier cooking a piece of
cake Caraway homes non-toxic
kitchenwares are all designed for the
modern home and feature a chemical free
ceramic coating so food can be prepared
with peace of mind that no hard to
pronounce compound will leach into your
healthy ingredients you know I hosted
Rosh Hashanah 10 people on Sunday night
and I use my Caraway cookware and it was
honestly like not being drama queen like
it was so much easier of a cleanup there
was no crusty Crustaceans there was no
crustacean like it was the
I made asparagus in there it's right off
was it asparagus yeah slipped I almost
fell on the floor for how slippery it
was it was really fabulous and it makes
your kitchen obviously a more efficient
place but also a more stunning place
because I have like a like the baby pink
collection it's just like why are men so
[ __ ] butt ugly like for real like
fugly ugly pants these are really cute
you can choose whatever color like cream
colored ones they're literally gorgeous
and it goes with your home Vibe for me
like the pink is so I'm like so stylish
so all their sets come equipped with
easy access storage solution so there is
no stacking required you are never going
to misplace your Lids again if you live
in a tiny apartment and you have like
one drawer for all your pots and pans
and you know like the stacking is the
bane of your existence look into the
cookware set and the bakeware set from
Caraway home the cookware is a modern
and chemical free iteration of the 16
piece set because nobody needs 16 pieces
they've boiled it down to the four
Essentials a frying pan a saute pan a
dutch oven and a saucepan thank you the
bakeware set is an assortment of
non-toxic baking Essentials that every
modern kitchen needs so you can get to
baking Goods without any of the bads so
again they're non-toxic it's easy
cooking and they are well loved over 25
000 people have raved about their
Caraway Kitchen products it is time for
you to try it for yourself visit
carawayhome.com
TMT to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 10 off your next purchase
this deal is exclusive for our listeners
so visit carawayhome.com TMT or use code
TMT at checkout Caraway non-toxic
cookware made Modern
all right deer toasters Our advice
segment you want to write in it's deer
toasters gmail.com and you'll get really
kind of profound honest advice from two
girls who really care about you yeah
that's true hello ladies please help we
have a solid group of girls in my friend
group we've all been friends for the
last five years however there's one gal
let's call her Jax that is single and
late night
she's single and lately has only been
going after guys that are in
relationships some have turned into
actual Affairs in the workplace even
yikes that's what she wrote ironic yikes
and some she just sends flirty text
messages too and tells us this guy could
be the one I'm sure it's a defense
mechanism because she's got cheated on
in her prior three relationships but
what the hell we've tried talking to her
about it and warning her but she won't
stop
most of us are in serious relationships
and we just can't believe we're good
friends with someone who willingly tries
to tear relationships apart in the past
we've all talked so much [ __ ] on home
Wreckers and now she's doing it and she
seems almost proud help do we let it go
do we sit her down actually have an
intervention Center to rehab LOL kidding
we're at a loss but it's getting
exhausting for all of us to keep the
friendship uh when all she talks about
is guys that are in relationships also
is it weird that I'm starting to lose
trust in her as a person of course we
are all in our 30s early 30s if that
matters okay love you bye yeah I feel
like at this point like you're you guys
are a little too old to be acting like
that like that's [ __ ] people did in
their like late teens early 20s not
something that you do
like as a pattern no I wouldn't bring
this girl around my man she obviously
has no respective relationship this girl
at arm's length obviously I would maybe
say something to her if she was like why
are you guys treating me differently
like and just be like you have no
Scruples and right it makes me
uncomfortable I don't know how to stop
you from doing what you're gonna do like
you're a grown woman but I our values
don't align right like I'm almost at the
place where I'll be entering my 30s and
I'm I plan on living in extremely
crippled life and I want to be
surrounded by scrupled people to energy
and this is
there was a video that went running on
Tick Tock this girl she's like I'm 25.
today's my birthday and here's questions
I have for people in their 30s and this
girl answered and she was like because
one of the questions was how do I make
you know more friends in my 30s and the
girl answered she was like you don't
like your circle gets smaller and it's
better like you don't need a million
friends people are not meant to be in
your life forever some people are and
some people aren't so to move forward
with only scrupled people I think that's
a really great way to go yeah because
your circle will get smaller as you get
older if you get married or you start a
family like you have less time for
people so you just want to stay close
with the ones you're closest to and
people fall by the way said if she's
going to behave like this like she'll be
the first to go no and honestly you are
who you associate with and like not like
not to be shallow but like you don't
want people thinking like you're okay
with that you know yeah no I I couldn't
be around and honestly the way you write
about her doesn't seem like you have
like great affection for her like you
would you'd be okay with letting her go
yeah I mean if you want to have a
conversation about it without you to
save everyone like 30s sometimes people
have a hard time dropping people that's
something that some people yes won't you
can't do
um for me it takes me a long time to get
to that place but once I once I'm there
goodbye agreed uh but some people that's
not in their vocabulary so if you want
to have a conversation
just be honest you're like what are you
doing the way that you this path that
you're going down is not something that
I want to be around for it's offensive
to me as a married person like to know
that you don't respect relationships and
we don't have anything in common if
that's what you're going to be doing no
you don't respect wood
do you know that no from curb like if
you put your cup on a wood table without
a coaster you don't respect wood God you
don't respect that is always saying
respect but for someone who's literally
never used a coaster in his life
um yeah which he said next up hey
Jackson Claude OG breath are here and
I'm gonna need some I'm I am in need of
some advice about
um
no it's just a weird way of phrasing
like oh I was gonna say like is this not
no it's actually very appropriate based
on what you're doing for today but said
okay
Botox okay
I'm in need of advice if there's such
thing as too much Botox my friend Ruthie
just started working as an esthetician
about a year ago she's absolutely
beautiful stunning and smart but has
recently been starting getting lip
injections and Botox without which I
have nothing against at all fellow Botox
are here the problem is our friends have
been coming up to me asking if she's had
actual work done to her face like going
under the knife because what's happening
to her she still looks gorgeous but she
looks different do I say something
before she gets too much done or let her
do whatever makes her feel like her best
self sincerely a toaster who doesn't
want her BFF to end up botched yeah it's
like on the one hand you want to empower
her to feel her best like I was having
this conversation at dinner last night
because someone I was with was talking
about how they want to get something
done I'm like just do it and she was
like really sure if it's bothering you
just fix it like I'm very much a
proponent of that but sometimes like
it's like when you're editing a picture
you get so in the weeds with editing
when you take a zoom out you really
can't see if you look that different so
it takes like a fresh perspective so I
don't know if like you would be
offending her like in the sense that she
likes the way that she looks or maybe
she's too in it she can't see out yeah I
I would try and like bring up the topic
of conversation of Botox Spillers maybe
be like I'm thinking about doing this
and see what she used to say about it be
like how much have you done be like and
so that amount that you did in your
lipstick is that what you're going to do
again when are you going to do it and
see if she has any sort of reservation
reservation or she's like I don't know
if this is for me like what do you think
like just wait and say open the door
just open the door and take her
temperature on how she's feeling because
if she's feeling herself like don't say
anything yeah you don't need to tell her
that she's like looking crazy because
she might be happy with how she looks
and then all of a sudden like you just
put this thing in her head yeah totally
and by the way it's like you have to
wait like six months for it to go away
so like she's gonna be insecure for the
next six months so I would just bring up
injectables as a topic of conversation
and see where she's at and if she's like
looking for opinions and if she's not I
wouldn't offer any it's her life I agree
and like
just because you like someone thinks
something looks bad it's subjective
right like yeah maybe she looks great
you know she's happier than ever yeah
but I do I do think plastic surgery like
is a slippery slope and sometimes people
get like so far down and then years
later they'll look at pictures of
themselves and be like wow it looks
crazy like I wish somebody had told me
right but even if somebody had told you
like there was no stopping you it's true
it's like our third and final is an
update from the girl who wrote in last
week about her mother-in-law who like
literally is obsessed with her
um
husbands like XA is always commenting on
social media friend requesting and just
being a general freak update
he talked to his mother my mother-in-law
she cried
she came over the next day she brought
me flowers and she apologized
am I the big fat wench now thanks for
your advice on this it really echoed
with what my friends were telling me but
I thought I should get an outsider
looking in opinion and you all match my
energy hahaha I don't think you should
feel like the way I'm gonna die the hero
or live long enough to really big fat
one it's like it's like unless you
defend yourself
you're a victim and then if you do
defend yourself you're the villain
you're the villain
no but like mother-in-law is like can
can be like so apologetic because
they're like old and frowned and like
then you feel bad yeah but you know what
mission accomplished and now just be
super sweet to her because now she wants
to hang with you tabula rasa that's what
you got right right you know now she's
not harping on the other girl she's
gonna want your time you have to play
Words With Friends with her and you're
gonna she's becoming on your post and
you're gonna have to respond so
responding to every story yeah so yeah
because it's the one you got
yeah wow we really kind of set you up
for that like no no but it's good that
was weird it had to end no and she had a
lot of like energy to give and now you
need to be the receiver right she's
clearly just like a person who
distributes love so now it's all coming
your way she like kind of is like a love
bomber you know
good luck with that
good because it's the one you got
everyone who wrote in thank you so much
dear toasters gmail.com we're always
here for you that is our show Jackie's
getting a haircut extra extra read all
about it thank you so much for listening
to the morning testimonial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribing this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and where podcasts can be
available
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow back in studio with
Jackson Cloud on Thursday bye bye